hey is with us in Missouri hey Kay how
are you I'm doing well thank you so much
for taking my call
absolutely how can we help so my husband
and I we are thankfully so employed we
are considered essential in our area
even though we have mandated stay at
home owners so we are still working
things are changing though in terms of
our jobs responsibilities due to limited
staffing at other locations and things
are starting to feel a little uneasy the
only debt we have is student loans that
we pay significantly on but it is one of
the loans that would qualify for no
interest and no required payment for six
months and so my question is just during
this am i uneasiness would it be okay if
we banked that in savings and then at
the end of the six months if everything
you know if we're so employed and things
are okay we'll just drop it there or
should we continue to at least pay you
know the minimum maybe not what we've
been because that's our honey not for
one day so we we currently pay way over
the minimum I'm just kind of well you're
on your own what we call baby step to
paying off your debts everything but
your house and what we tell folks is if
your income is stable and you think it's
going to be there to the extent you
think it's going to be there I would
just continue getting out of debt now if
you're if it's a if it's scary and you
don't think it's going to be there then
you stop your baby steps we're not
changing the order of them we're just
saying stop a storm is coming in your
particular life brought on by the
outside storm and so you're gonna
temporarily stop and pile up cash until
the storm has gone by not six months but
until the storm is gone by in other
words until you lose the fear that
you're gonna lose your job so let's
pretend for a second that in May your
organization is back to work and the
economy is back moving again let's just
pretend that okay I don't know but let's
in other
your fear on your job would have
dissipated greatly at that point agreed
where we are if that's where we are
that's what I said I let's pretend let's
visit that world for a minute and so if
that's where we are things are somewhat
back to normal then you no longer have a
fear then you just restart your baby
steps and any money you saved you throw
it the student loan mm-hmm
but no we're not gonna write a
government program of delayed payments
or interest we're gonna still get out of
debt as fast as we possibly can by the
way if they're not charging you interest
it'll help you get out of debt faster I
know it's kind of a situation to be in
but yeah but you're gonna have that
you're gonna have that regardless you
don't have to wait six months to pay on
okay you can go I'm getting out of this
thing yes but if you want to stop your
baby steps temporarily because you're
worried about your employment situation
and pile up some cash as soon as you're
not worried about it anymore take that
cash and throw it at the student loan
and kit and push play again and take
back off those of you that have lost
your jobs and that kind of stuff you're
in one of these you know situations
where you're with a retailer or you're
in the hospitality world bars
restaurants hotels rental car companies
whatever you're you know you're in
Cruise Lines Airlines that kind of stuff
you know you're you're at home you're on
you're at full stop on your baby steps
and preserving and piling up any cash
you can pile up and then again when
you're back to normalize with your
employment and your income then you push
play and go again and can we're seeing a
lot of that a lot of people that are
sitting there going okay what do i do
what do I do what I do and it's natural
because we don't know the timeline of
all this you know the end of the day you
know we don't know what governors are
gonna say we don't we don't know where
this thing is going this virus you know
there's just a new new chart coming out
every day and the reality is is what
you've got to do is is look at the big
picture and don't do anything that harms
the big picture because of this
short-term fear and the short-term pain
but the other thing is this if you are
one of those people and the hers is not
that case
that's right but if you are one of those
people that have gotten laid off let's
say you were working at a at a Marriott
Marriott laid off two rounds of ten
thousand people you're a marking and
Macy's you know they'll a hundred
thousand people we're going to rent a
car companies Hertz Avis enterprise of
laid off 7080 percent of their workforce
and so you're at home mmm
you don't have a job at all I'm an
income at all there's lots of people
hiring in the essential even when
there's a stay-at-home order in the
essential areas and so the Amazon
deliveries UPS FEDEX are hiring all the
pizza companies are hiring all the
grocery stores are hiring Aldi Kroger
Publix Target up there's $2 an hour
Walmart upstairs and and they've got a
hundred thousand people on the books to
hire Lowe's is hiring Whole Foods
7-eleven the Army National Guard this is
the latest stuff out here you're looking
for warehouses where you've got
industries that are moving I mean just
whatever you gotta give stocking shelves
is not a career choice no this is I need
some money
in my house to keep food on the table
and because I suddenly don't have any
income and it's for you know you may do
it for 30 days you may do it for 60 days
that's right and then you'll be back to
your old career or maybe you never go
back to your oak workers you hate it in
the first place hey 70% of Americans
didn't like their job going into this
thing this could be getting kicked out
of the nest the nudge that you needed
and that's why we've been telling people
in the Ken Cohen show hey I hate that
you've lost your job but this is the
time for you to reset right now and
prepare in the downtime I'm ready to go
you lost a job that you hate this is an
opportunity to get a job you like well
that's fair you're right I just hate
that they're feeling my unction the
answer yeah but you're absolutely right
I mean this is the nudge that many of
you need really